la central nuclear de saporilla está
cada vez más en riesgo por la guerra
Esta es la alerta del director general
de la agencia internacional de energía
atómica en un comunicado Rafael grossi
advirtió sobre el riesgo de un grave
accidente nuclear la situación general
en el área cercana a la planta de
energía nuclear de saporillas está
volviendo cada vez más impredecible y
potencialmente peligrosa estoy
extremadamente preocupado por los
riesgos muy reales de seguridad y
protección nuclear para la planta
debemos actuar de la mano para evitar la
amenaza de un accidente nuclear Severo y
sus consecuencias para las personas y el
medio ambiente una situación inestable
provocada por las operaciones militares
en torno a esta planta la más grande de
Europa y que las fuerzas rusas tomaron
desde marzo de 2022 al inicio de la
guerra y aunque los seis reactores están
apagados el riesgo de un desastre en
caso de bombardeo sigue siendo
importante según informó la agencia
expertos del oia presentes en el lugar
permanentemente dicen que dejaron
bombardeos el pasado 5 de Mayo según
analistas la contraofensiva anunciada
recientemente por Ucrania Podría tener
lugar en la región de saporilla
controlada en un 80% por las fuerzas
rusas ante la intensificación de los
bombardeos El oficial regional instalado
por moscúa aseguró que inició las
evacuaciones de civiles de 18
localidades en particular de nergodar
para enviarlos a ciudades aledañas
70.000 personas deberían ser evacuadas
de esta forma pero por ahora los
empleados de la planta no están
incluidos según las autoridades rusas